hey this is Rich I'm the maintainer of
the GT package 0.7 is out so let's see
what she in it
feature one the new word output table
format for GT with that you could output
a table to an Word document and here's
an example right here inside our studio
I'm going to load up GT I have this
example table called exhibble we can
make a GT table out of that and if you
use GT save we could output that to a
Word document we just have to use dot
docx in the file extension feature
number two is a whole new class of
vector formatting functions and they can
be used outside of GT proper all the
work that was put into the column
formatting functions like format number
format scientific now you get that
outside of GTA anywhere you want to use
it say for instance inside of quarto or
on markdown inside a paragraph you want
to have some format numbers or or
currency values now you can have that
without having to hack something
together with GT and it's column
formatters so another new feature we
have this is feature number three is the
newest opt stylize function with that if
you have a GT table and you don't want
to style it with a lot of tab options or
tab style statements you can just use op
stylize you give the style number you
give it a color and GT just takes it
away and stylizes your table with a nice
set of colors and line styles
uh for all the different parts of your
table
and here's an example over here my
viewer I just ran it over this code
right here which created a table with
all sorts of different uh locations like
summaries and footnotes and a header you
can see right here just by using stop
stylize we get a very nice table as a
result and you can switch the color out
if you really want to
feature four is new function called tab
step indent what it allows you to do is
to take roll labels in the stub and
indent them before you could not do that
very easily by adding spaces or things
like that very manual not so easy but
with tap some indent you just give the
rows you want to match and you just
choose the indent level you can also use
increase or decrease here it's really
quite nice and I'm just going to run
this code and we see that the sizes here
are indented by two tab stops which is
really nice we selected all these with a
matches statement and you can do all
sorts of nice things with indentation
with tab stuff and dent
so again in the future five we have a
new function called format duration it's
a formatting function and it allows you
to take any value it could be numerical
values or it could be diff time values
and format them as duration values this
is really quite neat so I'm going to
show you this in an example here we have
some SP 500 data we're doing some stuff
to it and a main thing we're doing in
the time past column is running the
format duration so let's actually see
that in a table
and we can see here that uh just with
the default options or very default
defaulty options we have the time pass
column it's got number of days it added
the days uh to it which is quite nice
and we can you know choose things we can
have things like narrow here and we run
the code and we get things like this we
have a narrow days designation
uh so if you have complex time scoring
in the past this will also work it'll
break it down into different time parts
and it looks really great in the table
and because we have these formatting
functions in Vector formatters now this
also exists as vector format duration in
feature six we have an upgraded GT safe
and it uses webshot too it's a better
webshot it's a sequel to the webshot
package and the main thing to know there
is that it doesn't use Phantom JS it
uses promote and promote is the thing
that will take the screenshot of the
table
and because of all this you get better
PNG snapshots of your table and you'll
just generally have a better experience
because before
uh well it wasn't so good you'd have
weird things like uh well it was blurry
for one thing and also uh certain things
like bold text did not work at all uh
which was quite annoying for a lot of
people I can imagine but now this fixes
it ugt save in 0.7 uh it just does the
trick in feature seven we have
accessibility improvements for screen
readers so if you use the screen reader
you'll find that tables are read more
accurately especially complex tables
so that's what's in 0.7 of GT check out
the blog post on our studio.com and also
check out the new Twitter account
at underscore package